Water
earth
fire
air
Happy New Year everyone welcome back this is
going to be my new avatar the last airbender
video there have been a lot of people asking
what's going on with the new netflix series
what's going on with new versions of animated
avatar the last airbender series so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos i
will be doing avatar videos throughout the year
just because things are starting to spin up in
the avatar universe and if you have no idea what's
going on in the past couple of months there's been
talk from the viacom ceo about new animated
avatar the last airbender because of their
new streaming service that they're rolling out
so if you remember the big disney investor day
that they did a while ago with all the big marvel
trailers all the big star wars trailers for the
10 new marvel tv shows and 10 new star wars tv
shows that they're rolling out on disney plus
in the next couple of years viacom is doing their
own version of that with all their brands on the
new service that they're calling paramount plus
i know very original name just add plus to the
end of your name and this is me just reading from
his comments he says in terms of paramount plus we
have announced some new entertainment franchises
that were bringing to plus the godfather spongebob
criminal minds spin out but under the covers our
preview launch show that there's other franchises
that will work too and have potential like mtv's
reality shows the challenge things like nick's
animated library series avatar and all this is
really tip of the iceberg and we do have other
franchises of the company so you can safely assume
that the upcoming announcements will include new
original variants of them for paramount plus of
all this library stuff that they're talking about
we will of course have non-franchise-based new
originals to keep things fresh but i'm not going
to get ahead of things and reveal them until we
get much closer to launch so because we're in 2021
now they're actually getting much closer to doing
their version of the disney plus investor date
where they actually announce what some of that
new programming is going to be for the streaming
service because before he mentioned new avatar the
last airbender content new shows within the avatar
universe the stuff that he read off like the
spongebob the godfather stuff a lot of that's not
going to get people to pay for another streaming
service but avatar the last airbender has the
potential to be one of those big ticket items that
gets old fans the older people now who were fans
of the original series when it first aired and all
the younger people who are hungry for something
that's a little more complex than spongebob who
are just burnt out on a lot of the same old same
old that they've been rolling out for the last
10 years what they're doing with their service
though is that if you're paying for cbs all access
right now that's basically their streaming service
they're going to rename that paramount plus so
if you're already paying for that you will get
the paramount plus streaming service but if you've
been following mike and brian for the past couple
of years obviously there's been all this news
about the avatar the last airbender netflix series
the new version of the series that they're doing
for netflix and it was a big blowout that they
had during 2020 is if 2020 couldn't be bad enough
last summer when they posted their announcements
about why they were leaving the project and all
the disagreements that they had with netflix over
the creative on that show they also slipped in
a lot of references about working on potential
future avatar projects within the universe just
on the sly like oh by the way we're leaving this
big netflix show that we've been talking about
for the past couple of years but we also might
be working on some new avatar projects in the
future as well because if you remember a couple
years ago it was at the end of 2018 when they
first announced they were doing a live-action
netflix avatar the last airbender version a lot
of people were like why are they doing it live
action why don't they just do a new animated
series set in the avatar universe that seems
like a no-brainer pretty much anybody who's been a
fan of the series just wants to see another avatar
series set in the universe during a different
part of the timeline with another new avatar
viacom is so thirsty to get people to subscribe
to their new paramount plus streaming service
the only way you do that is with really compelling
programming so no surprise that they've probably
been asking mike and brian pretty much every year
on the regular to do a new animated avatar series
what do we have here the way mike and brian
explained it is when they did the original avatar
the last airbender series is that it took him
about four years to develop the project it took
a long time to bring it from concept to actual
episodes so if they were to do a new animated
series we might not see it for a while and there
was some clauses in their contract with netflix
that probably stated that they couldn't just turn
around and do another new avatar series right away
with someone else like the new viacom streaming
service they got paid a big chunk of money by
netflix they also get paid every time the avatar
series and legend of korra go to new streaming
services so don't worry too much about them they
just got paid big time because both avatar and
cora hit netflix in the last year but just in
terms of what that new avatar animated series
would be i think most of us are in agreement that
they should complete the avatar cycle or at least
go to the next step in the avatar cycle and
just do a series based on an earthbender avatar
normally you would just assume they would just
continue forward in the timeline but one of the
issues that a lot of you have also asked about
on my previous avatar videos is that they were to
do that then they would actually turn into like a
cyberpunk avatar series like do we want an avatar
series where they're walking around with iphones
remember during legend of korra they're kind of in
like the 1920s 1930s era they have cars they have
airships so if cora lives for like another 40 or
50 years you're basically really close to present
day with modern day technology there's been a lot
of fan art of the avatar characters in modern day
clothing and it actually looks pretty cool but i
don't know how cool a series set during that era
would be so the obvious conclusion is that they
should just do a series with an earthbender
avatar said in the past and who is the most
notable earthbender avatar set in the past it
would be avatar kyoshi of course just do an avatar
kyoshi series if you haven't been reading all the
expanded material they just released the rise of
kyoshi in the shadow of kiyoshi novels but it only
covers a little bit of her life and it's actually
really really fascinating i would say just in
terms of avatars that they've actually done a good
job of developing within the other shows kiyoshi
is at the top of that list next to avatar 1 she's
probably the most hyped up version of the avatar
that just hasn't gotten her own series yet avatar
kyoshi is like the stabby avatar in fact during
those kyoshi's stories that they just published
a little while ago she has her own version of a
darth vader rogue one hallway scene just wrecking
a bunch of firebenders we've even started to
see a lot of fan animation for avatar kyoshi
series and it's actually pretty solid what do you
think you're doing the lady asked you to step away
you want in on this transaction hey i don't
care if it's you or this i just like good times
good times are over as cool as that is if
for some reason they just didn't want to do
an avatar kyoshi series they could do another
earthbender avatar from somewhere earlier in
the timeline as well i just don't see them doing
a modern day avatar series it just doesn't feel
like the series would work as well if you did
it in modern day there was also a big avatar
of the last airbender reunion this past day i
haven't had a chance to watch the entire reunion
video it was mostly the cast and the crew just
getting together talking about their favorite
moments and their memories from the series
dante bosco has been like a thousand percent
more involved with avatar since it hit netflix
he also clarified that he would still love to
be involved with future avatar projects i mean
his voice is so identifiable even if he played
another character the minute you hear him talk
you instantly think of zuko you know when when
when the time's right uh you know you catch me
you know i might pop in somewhere anywhere who
knows people that follow my career know i'm
like i'm one of them actors that can pop up
anywhere at any time you know after 30 years of
industry is like yeah dante's he said initially
he had talked about consulting on the avatar the
last airbender netflix series but before that
actually really turned into a big thing mike and
brian wound up leaving the project he said he'd
still have to be involved with that series if it
winds up working out but he said he's also got
an upcoming meeting with mike and brian via zoom
to talk about all things avatar in the universe
so it sounds like they'll also talk a little bit
about potential future animated projects as well
but just in terms of when they'd actually be
able to do a new animated series remember there's
probably a little bit of a cooling off period with
their netflix contract so they'd have to wait a
little while before they could actually develop
one but they do have the upcoming paramount
plus investor meeting hopefully they'll announce
something about the avatar franchise during that
my assumption is they were to start an avatar
project in the next year or two it would take
them to like 2023 2024 before you actually see
any kind of test animation or anything like that
but just in terms of what's going on with that
avatar the last airbender netflix series after
they left the project so netflix is still making
that they didn't say when they plan on releasing
it but pretty much all the people they hired to
help them develop that project are still working
on it they said that they trust them so i have a
feeling that it'll at least be okay but hopefully
we'll get a look at what it's going to actually
be in the next year or so but hopefully that
explains what's going on it just sounds exciting
2021 already looking up so much better than 2020
potential new animated avatar the last airbender
series so everyone let me know in the comments
what kind of new animated series would you want
them to do if they can do anything that they want
you may remember the rumors about an avatar the
last airbender season four i did a video about
what that story would have been it was aaron ehasz the head writer on the original animated
series that was talking about his pitch for
what avatar season four would have been you
can click here to find out what that story would
have been it would have mostly focused on azula
and click here for all my marvel phase 4 trailer
videos for the marvel shows that are starting
next week with Wandavision thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and happy new year!